- I never had the grand intention
that I wanted to be an accordion
store owner when I grew up.
I had seen accordions before,
but until I actually picked one up,
and played the notes,
and moved the bellows,
I just, it was one of those moments where,
where has this been all my life?
(accordion music)
I am the owner of one of the largest
accordion shops in the world.
(accordion music)
I started with the accordion when
I was about to head off to college.
I was trying to figure out how
I was going to play piano there,
and I remembered that
my dad played accordion.
It's really great to get to know my dad
through something that he really liked,
and something that was important to him,
which was music.
He unfortunately died
when I was five years old,
so I really didn't know him very well.
You know, the ability to connect,
I think it's something that
I always wish I had with my dad,
but, you know, I look
forward to having with Reed.
(playing Jingle Bells)
My son started on a toy
accordion at age two.
I think if he's anything like me or my dad
then he'll like music,
and it's perfectly fine with me
if he plays another instrument.
I just want to ultimately
be able to connect with him
and it's a great experience
to express yourself
through a musical instrument.
I think this one's really a great sound
for like a tango music.
Possibly could also pass this
as Count Dracula's private accordion.
I sometimes use that in combination
(laughing) with my Dracula fang costume.
Probably should cut that part.
In the U.S., there's very few people
that know a lot about accordions
and that can repair them.
Many of the people that had that knowledge
were retiring and really not interested
in expanding out to the internet.
We started in my apartment,
ya know, just listing things on eBay.
And we realized it was
a great business model.
It's amazing to just
type in a few key words
and see new and used accordions
from all over the world.
Reed is growing up in an environment
where he sees accordions all the time,
so naturally he thinks
that a lot of people
play the accordion.
And he gets to see me perform,
he gets to see my band
Polkadelphia perform.
- Three, two, one,
(polka music)
♫ There's a store in Philly
where accordion is king.
♫ We only sell one thing,
so hear our bellows ring ♫
- I'm looking forward to
connecting with my son
in the same way that I often wished
my dad had the opportunity
to work with me.
The most important thing for me
is to instill that sense of
finding what he really likes
and something that he'll wake up each day
and be excited about.
♫ Liberty Bellows, Liberty Bellows,
♫ The one stop squeezebox shop ♫